if you want to see have how pervasive
all of this is Dr Simone gold who was
one of the front line doctors right at
the very beginning of kovid who was
saying we need to think about these
things differently and that masks don't
make sense and social distancing is a
farce and we shouldn't be locking people
down and we have to be wary of the
vaccines and all of that stuff she
eventually because she showed up at the
Capitol on January 6 ended up in jail
for two or three months she just got out
she put up this tweet I mean this is
just if you want to see how how
incredible it is how the machine
operates wow Pfizer ran paid vaccine
promotion that tells children to go to a
website to view a Marvel comic book that
advertises their vaccines this shocking
advertisement targeting minors should be
illegal and yes it is true here is a
tweet from Pfizer they sponsored an
Avengers cartoon when Ultron wreaks
Havoc The Avengers act as the first line
of defense people can help protect
themselves by staying up to date with
their covid-19 vaccinations head on over
to blah blah blah and buy the freaking
comic book so do you see how the machine
despite the fact
that right now our Surgeon General in
Florida is releasing a study showing
that there are heart issues with 18 to
39 year olds the machine Pfizer which
sponsors all of the news shows that
people watch on Sundays and every night
on cable news uh we got a problem here I
think you got it we got a problem here
and it's continuing so now to to back up
a little bit also to what bill and I
were talking about this divide between
Florida and California these are the two
these are the two faces of the nation
let's say and we have to pick which way
we're going to go well Simone gold
continued on Twitter when it came to
California she said California just
became the first state in the nation to
mandate that all children take mRNA
vaccines in order to attend school
Florida on the other hand now recommends
against the MRNA vaccine for males 18 to
39 years old Florida follows the science
California does not so this divide it is
widening and I think actually it's good
that it's dividing if you live in
California right now and you just want
to keep injecting your kids with a bunch
of stuff that you have no idea what it's
doing on top of the fact that the the
virus is 99 Point whatever it is 997
recovery rate for kids and now there's
all of these studies that are starting
to show that there are heart issues and
other side effects if you want to keep
doing that California and you want to
keep voting for people like avenuesome
then I guess stay in California and
we'll see the results of this over the
years and I would say 10 20 years from
now there's going to be a whole bunch of
kids who had been locked down and masked
up and injected with all kinds of stuff
who are going to be not very kind when
they're putting their parents into old
age homes